trent thornton will open the home stand
and this game for the blue jays and
should give them multiple innings before
the rest of the bullpen takes over
that was the game plan the last time out
for trent when he opened up versus the
red sox two scoreless innings in that
game trey turner stands in the nationals
need to get things going offensively
there's no two ways about it and a
breaking ball hit in the air to left
field deep this is way back this may go
and it is gone goodbye
bang zoom goes turner it's the nationals
one of the blue jays nothing just like
that now yada yada hernandez bouncing
ball up the middle panicked near the bag
at second throws in time went away
so one out of nobody on a ryan zimmerman
bouncing ball panic cuts in front of
the shed and the throw is wide of the
mark but guerrero as he has done so
often putting a good stretch on it and
helps out one of his defenders josh bell
the batter there's a bouncing ball past
thornton
cashette makes a good play behind the
bag and after the lead off home run
trent thornton three times a sign in
order we're gonna have fun watching this
guy pitch tonight max scherzer is riding
a really strong streak
coming into this outing 17 straight
scoreless innings for mad max facing
kevin biggio leading it off
the third base line that's going to be a
hit no problem at all and we'd love to
see that more often when they play in
the shift you got to do something to
counteract it to get your lanes back and
that'll do it at the lead-off button now
boba sheds the shot does strike out a
lot swinging a miss
and that was a quick moving slider going
down and away strikes him out max has
his first k so now the batter is
vladimir guerrero jr he's all for his
last 10. slider hit on the ground left
side turner backhands to second for one
harrison the first the short hop dug out
by ryan zimmerman and that's a double
play to retire the side
harrison hurried couldn't get a lot on
it but zim is able to pick it and the
inning comes to a close right there kyle
schwarber will lead off the second
inning there's a breaking ball swinging
a miss robert strikes out for strike out
of the ball game for trent thorne that
comes on a curve ball here's harrison
banning sixth in the order oh
harrison immediately telling his dugout
he's okay as he's drilled by that
fastball on his hands so harrison aboard
with one out and here's starlin castro
there goes the runner the throw from
kirk is a good one right on the money
and that's the first base runner he's
thrown out this year base dealers were
eight for eight against
kirk and boy he threw a c down yeah this
time one away in the top of the third
back to the top of the order trey got
the gnats on the board right out of the
gates in this one swinging a high drive
left center field does he have another
one going back guerrielle to the track
to the wall and that one is long gone
it's trey turner two and the blue jays
nothing seventh career multi-homer game
hernandez grounded out to the third
baseman in the shift his only timeout
here's a swing and a long drive to left
for hernandez he does a little bat flip
as this one's gonna go
a long home run over the left center
field wall for yadiel hernandez
and against two different pitchers the
nationals go back to back and they lead
the blue jays three to nothing it's the
matchup everybody's looking for bases
loaded one out vlade guerrero against
max schurzer blue jay's down by three
just saying a big fly puts him ahead
that is now all for his last 11.
swinging to drive get up buck get out of
here and grand slam for vladi guerrero
jr
that's what we came for
with that grand slam
that puts the blue jays up
third career grand slam for guerrero and
abujas have erased a three-nothing
deficit here castro comes in with the
bases loaded to face victor robles in
the fourth inning with toronto trying to
hold on to the lead one-two ground ball
this should be two beshet to simeon back
to first double play what a job by
castro he bears out tommy malone who had
loaded the bases
and castro gets out of it with the
double play that's a lead off double for
joe panic so the blue jays
have had seven hits
against scherzer in the first three plus
innings for the number nine hitter
alejandro kirk this is popped up
right side of the infield josh harrison
backing up into the outfield goes off
his glove and past the right fielder
panic's going to come in to score
wow
a gift for the blue jays a drop pop-up
by harrison it's 5-3 toronto this is a
team washington who came in this game
with just nine errors all season long so
now they have to bring the infield in
three on the right side against cabin
biggio fly bar that'll score a run kirk
tagging up at third robles backs up
here's the throw to home and it's
offline and here comes kirk can the blue
jays have a three-run lead runners on
first and second and two out of the top
of the fifth the blue jays leading by
the score of six to three and there's a
liner who left and guerrilla was
positioned perfectly
trover went the other way hit a line
drive but gurio was there to end the
inning meza strands a couple of vladimir
guerrero will lead off the fifth inning
swinging the drive deep to center get up
ball get out of here
his second home run of the night to
straight away center
and the blue jays now lead it by the
score of seven to three a one out single
so the batter now is ryan zimmerman
here's the pitch
swinging a drive deep to right big sound
off the back biggio at the wall looking
up and it's gone
opposite field booming two-run homer for
ryan zimmerman and the nationals cut the
deficit in half so bows aboard with one
out guerrero with five rbis has tied his
career high swing in the drive get up
ball get out of here how about a three
homer night for vlady
a career high and home runs and rbis for
vladimir guerrero jr
and so much for that oh for 10 streak
rafael dolis will come on to try to
close out this game it is not a save
situation the blue jays lead it nine to
five and elise has really thrown the
ball well little jam looper shallow
center field oh the shortstop is out he
makes the catch and rublishes retired
he's all performed ground ball big hop
to boba shed it's short one hop across
the diamond and guerrelle handles it
easily guerrero's been the offensive
star no question he's made a couple of
good plays over at first
on low throws from buchet and the nats
are down to their final out of the game
here's the 2-2
swung on and missed and that's the ball
game the blue jays win it
they win game one of this two-game
series nine to five and vladimir
guerrero jr
a terrific three-homer seven rbi night
and he did it all for the blue jays
tonight